I love it
no that was not anything we're talking
about Ryan Ryan the right my name cuz
that's right or it could be left okay so
we're gonna watch the second trailer or
deliver us from evil the new children's
movie brought to you by DreamWorks
Animation that's what it is let's watch
it sergeant welcome oh my god
this looks like a good [ __ ] that's what
I do singing yeah it's usually black
people not to be racist or anything but
they're usually wants to shut up [ __ ]
keep your way Wow to that thing to a
whole other level oh my god what's
happening your windows caving that movie
looks really scary I like a good horror
movie I know typical here's some intense
music and then nothing actually doesn't
look like a scare festival yeah it looks
like it's actually really terrified yeah
back to Jerry Bruckheimer is producing
it I know it's gonna be yeah come on man
yeah yeah boys The Lone Ranger Dead
Man's Chest the story is probably gonna
be intense the idea that it's possibly
based on true story
everyone's like how they change all the
facts I'm like even yeah based on the
case files
so many times I just don't even know I
got Jesus she's in my heart I never
worry about this thing happening to me
well sometimes it goes after religious
figures even no exorcisms are real
another real I'm not worried about
getting what if it happening what if she
got possessed by a demon a really horny
okay I'll be there for you when it
happens the channel subscribe gotta make
sure to shot some people out Travian
Staton said he wanted to shout out said
it's funny know what that's like the one
thing people said he's really
good-looking has a great body huge wing
eating a link that's usually the word
they use to describe it but never funny
never funny yeah Thank You Travian funny
yep yep you're funny
you're no longer good looking good miles
Parkinson's disease all MIT I want to
give a shout-out to miles is gonna piss
off a lot of people that I was saying
this I want to give her shots of miles
way before I started even doing some
shout outs it was his first time he
requested one so I was like you know
what
it's a request this is my way of sucking
your dick my friend yeah Sally gets
turned on by a man on that action you
don't like it when guys do anything on
each other it's [ __ ] hot come on man
so you don't do it that's a shame cuz
when I think about Sally I think about
handle Jeff Gabriel he put this in a
comment so I'm gonna put her in a video
to make him more out there he's we going
through a rough patch you know it gets a
little depressed now and then I do too
yeah I do too man it's always in Sally
to rejects me that's the only time only
time and now she doesn't do anal so this
guy's already said that we make him feel
better and dad's like the number-one
reason like out of all reasons to keep
going is cousin reasons yes it's a
reference to another show on the channel
that's what we should call your ear ear
show it's just like reasons to Jerry
than you and Jerry will do a matchup
video me and Jerry should have our own
little show like go to Taco Bell and
talk
the worst movies ever there is a show
like that where they sit at a restaurant
and talk movies we're hoping to get some
endorsements so soft as a brainstem you
know they say youtubers get product
placement and we will gladly eat a bean
burrito as much as possible do you do
yeah well we're looking to partner up
April are you talked about every night
yeah everyone else gets diarrhea not her
not her me once she's immune diarrhea to
her body it's like kryptonite it's like
her body rejects it so much until never
happened I'm saying you're diarrhea's
weakness your diarrhea is kryptonite
okay
sure you make diarrhea week isn't
diarrhea like the most embarrassing
sickness they have yeah it's like oh I
got a bike on the lake you can't brag
about and be like yeah I was going
through those really painful time Santa
ritas just funny always there so when
you have diarrhea it sucks
oh my god no but then when you hear
about someone happy to hell you imagine
is like they're [ __ ] all the time
what is wrong with our world so if you
have diarrhea out there don't worry guys
hang in there we know what it's like
when everyone thinks you're a joke but
you're not no no we have meetings
everyone's